Путіну необхідно застосовувати домовленості
мінськ добросовісно один відновити
вірю, що я президент
республіка, я б сказав пану Путіну
анексію злочину я не приймаю
тому що це національне та мирне в
Україна і тоді ми
передати значення, які я вважаю
політики, яка проводилася протягом чотирьох
років тепер Франсуа Олланд на
ставлення до росії абсурдно і
що вона за кермом, що вона за кермом
Росія, до якої вона штовхає Росію
harden to isolate oneself активувати
націоналістичні рефлекси
але виявляється, що росія - це
це найбільша країна в світі
країна, яка наповнена ядерною зброєю
і яка тому є небезпечною країною
ставитися до цього так, як ми до нього ставилися
протягом п'яти років, тому я прошу
ми просто сидимо
столу також запитали
Американська угода